all right we start with this breaking
news and speaking of that gun violence
another deadly shooting here in the
valley this morning seven people have
been shot near unlv one of the victims
is dead right now metro police they are
looking for a gunman let's go live to
mary jane belliesa who is gathering
details at this hour
now this is as close as we can get to
the crime scene lieutenant jason
johansen with metro says they responded
to a shooting out here at 11 30 p.m at
the siegel suites behind me now what we
know so far is that lieutenant johansen
says one person has died six people were
transported to sunrise hospital and out
of those six two remain in critical
condition
right now based upon the preliminary
details that we have right now there was
a neighbor dispute
that escalated into a verbal argument
and during that verbal argument
there was an exchange of gunfire
resulting in the incident that we are
investigating right now
now lieutenant johansen says this is
especially troubling especially what
happened last weekend at the shooting at
manny's afterglow lounge out on sahara
and state street
they are still looking for the shooter
here so he encourages anybody with
details about the shooting at the segal
suites to call crime stoppers that's at
702-385-5555 you can remain anonymous
reporting live here on flamingo and
university drive mary jane balleza 8
news now